Now we follow the idea of associativety to the extreme
and let any cache block be put anywhere in the
cache. Returning to our example, if this was a direct
map cache, where every block has only one place to go.
And this was a set associative cache, where there was
a small set of places that a block can go. Then
this is a fully associative cache where all cache blocks
are treated alike and can be put anywhere in the cache.
Looking at a more general notation, then we see
that full associativity means we don't interpret any of
the address as index anymore. It's all tag. This
means that when we ask if a particular address is
stored in the cache. The hardware has to check
tags for every cache entry. Or at least, do
it sequentially really, really fast. This fact, generally limits
fully associative caches to sizes between 64 and 256 entries